أنا من مواليد حفر الباطن
حفر الباطن العظيمة
حارة صيفًا، باردة شتاءً
لطيفة في الربيع
تخرجت من الثانوية
من الحفر في 1993
كان الطموح عندي إني أُصبح طيار طبعًا
وقالوا فيه تقديم على الطيران في الخبر
كان عنده
متر على الباب
قال لي وقف على المتر
قال لا أنت ما تصلح
ليش؟
قال لي والله أنت ناقصك عشرة سنتيمتر
بعدين قرأت في الجريدة أنه
فيه تقديم على أرامكو
ونظام ابتعاث
فجيت أرامكو قلت لهم أنا أبغى طيران
قالوا ليش طيران؟
أنت نسبتك كويسة وبنودّيك ابتعاث
عندنا اللي هو
الإرشاد البحري وبحر وزي كذا
تعرف أنا جاي من الحفر
الحفر صحراء قاحلة يعني
وأول مرة أشوف البحر هنا حقيقةً
كان طموحي كابتن في الجو،
وأصبحت كابتن في البحر
كثير ناس تجيك تقول، أنا مثلًا كابتن
يقول لك أنا ما أعرف أنك كابتن طيارة
تقول مرشد، يقول إيش مرشد؟
يا شيخ السفينة في البحر ما تغرق؟
كيف ما تغرق؟ وهي حديد،
لا وفيها زيت...
أوه شهر تقعدون في البحر؟
إيه شهر، مرات شهرين
كيف الحال؟
هذا إحنا الحين في قيادة التحكم،
مثل ما أنتو شايفين
إذا غرقنا
هذا خط السفينة
نبحر من رأس تنورة من هنا على جنوب إفريقيا
رأس الرجاء الصالح
بعدين على الأطلسي
طبعًا الأطلسي
فيه الأعاصير كثيرة،
تجيك رياح أعاصير مخيفة جدًا
كل مرة يجي إعصار
يعرفون تقريبًا اتجاهه وين بيكون
فيحذرون السفن عن طريق الفاكس والأجهزة
أن الإعصار اتجاهه متوقع يوصل هنا اليوم
متوقع يوصل اليوم الفلاني
فالسفن إيش تسوي؟ تغير اتجاهها
الإعصار قبل لا نوصله تقريبًا بيومين،
غير اتجاهه فجأة
حوالينا في البحر طبعًا
هذولي كلهم تحت الموية
في الحالة هذه ممنوع إن أي أحد
يطلع على ظهر السفينة
وسط الإعصار، وضغط منخفض
وأسمع فيه رياح قوية
كلما طلعت برا الإعصار، الرياح تزيد
لأن على أساس تطلع
من دائرة الإعصار ويخليك فترة تلف
ضرب ليوم ونصف تقريبًا
الموجة نتكلم عن أربعة أمتار،
تضرب من قدام إلى آخر شيء، فتغطيها
الرحلة طبعًا من هنا
إلى هنا تأخذ خمسة وثلاثين يوم،
يعني شهر وشوي
-وين الحفر؟
-الحفر هنا
ما حطوها عشانها مو ميناء
هذه اليمن هذه عمان هذه الإمارات،
هذه روسيا
صارت حصة جغرافيا
طبعا الدراسة في الكلية البحرية تتطلب
إنك تطلع على السفن وتخدم
رخصة المزاولة اللي تاخذها
لازم تخدم تقريبًا
اثنى عشر شهر إلى أربع وعشرين شهر
وصلت السفينة
في الليل، وكنت لحالي
ولك تتخيّل يعني
واحد متخرج من الثانوي ومن حفر الباطن
فجأة إلى الظهران
إلى أمريكا على باخرة ألمانية
قعدت أقول أنا وين كنت؟
والحين أنا وين؟ في المحيط
هذا اللي قاعد أشوفه
أول يوم طبعًا قاعد في الغرفة ما طلعت
جتني مرحلة فكّرت قلت،
أنا أيش اللي جابني هنا؟
بس إني أتراجع، لا
في أرامكو أعطونا دورة تقريبًا مدتها
أسبوع قبل لا نسافر
يعني جابوا لنا دكاترة وزي كذا
وشرحوا لنا يعني ترى بتواجهون كذا،
اختلاف ثقافات، بتواجهون عزلة وغربة
وبالسفينة ممكن تقعد يوم كامل
ما تقدر تنام
لأن السفينة تميل مع الموج
هذه أشياء كويسة اللي
أخذناها قبل لا نروح هناك وننصدم
هذا المكتب الرئيس
هذا المسجل وهذه شرائطنا من داخل بعد
والله مشاعر ما أقدر أقول لك هي كيف
أكثر أحد يتأثر فيها أمي
رح أوريكم السفينة عشان ماما تشوفها
شريت كاميرا فيديو
وصوّرت رحلة كاملة من أمريكا إلى رأس تنورة
فقلت اليوم التاريخ كذا كذا،
وبصوّر لكم الرحلة
أشياء كثيرة تجدونها في
هذه السفينة الممتازة
يعني حاس باللحظات اللي أصورها الآن،
أنا حاس فيها يعني وأتذكرها لحظة لحظة
وهذه اللي على اليسار وهذه اللي على اليمين
وهذه اللي في الوسط
هذه تخزّن المويه عشان التوازن
هذه السفينة خريطة طبعًا
مرحبًا،
مساء الخير كابتن
هو أكثر شيء
ماكينة السفينة تخرب في وقت حرج
فالكابتن يسلمك سفينته زي اللي يسلمك رقبته
فأنت تحتاج تتخذ قرار في أقل من ثلاث ثواني،
والقرار هذا يحدد مصير السفينة
والسفينة ممكن تنكسر
هذه الأفلام
هذا صندوق البريد
طبعًا هذه أحسن اللحظات
إذا جاء الكابتن يوزّع الرسائل
يعني زي الأفلام توقف كذا،
وينادي الكابتن فلان
اللي ما تجيه رسالة يرجع
زيه زي اللي مكسور خاطره
طبعا هذا من أخوي
هو كان يكتب لأمي
تحية أبعثها إلى ولدي الغالي
معطرة بأجمل عطور العالم
كيف حالك؟
وما هي أخبارك؟
إن شاء الله تكون بخير وصحة جيدة
يا ولدي الغالي انتبه إلى صحتك، وأكلك
وهالله هالله بالدراسة عشان تتخرج بسرعة
أنا الحمد لله بخير وصحة جيدة
بس هذه اللي أقدر...
شوي كانت مؤثرة
الرسالة طبعًا ما تقرأها مرة واحدة وخلاص
تقرأها مرة، وبكرة مرة، وبكرة مرة
تقعد معك إلى أسبوع
وأنت تقرأ بالرسالة نفسها
البني آدم يقدر يتكيف مع أي بيئة
يقدر يتكيف مع أي عمل إذا أحبه